[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 68 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Francis Campo and I'm here with my
colleague mark Mendell hey Mark how are
you doing I'm doing well Francesca it's
a toll over next deserver listen to
listen to this silence silence I don't
back from music no background noise
we're back to her studio cloud mix is
over yah was amazing but we also very
happy that was pretty intense it was
pretty intense but it was really cool I
had an amazing time and I think a lot of
people did as well it was amazing
meeting so many people thanks to every
single one of the people that came by
and took pictures and just like wave our
azure came and said hi ask questions all
that stuff if you have pictures with any
of us or whatever the podcast send it to
us ogc podcast or will repeat all of
these things at the end yep but yeah
send them to us we'd love to have a
little bit of like a photo album
remember it yeah we got more worries
nice and thanks to everyone who sent me
a photos of dogs for my birthday oh yeah
however they've ever seen I appreciated
that alright cool cool why don't we why
don't we get started so we've got our
interview today which is with William
bunnell from the home depot the home
depot yeah indeed we're going to talk
about sre stuff at the home depot yeah
we interviewed him during climax so
you'll hear some of that beautiful
background that you might be history doc
but it was an amazing India it really
was really enjoyed it yep and then at
the end we'll have the question of the
week we recorded that question during
climax yeah we will give you the answer
today but before that we will start with
our cool things of the week and this
time we have 101 cool things of the week
yeah cool thing to see I think that's
good so I don't think we can go through
them all quite clearly for time
constraints but there is a blog post 100
announcements from google cloud necks
2017 from acquisitions partnerships new
products releases I really like identity
aware proxy because it's the thing that
we've been using internally for quite a
while and it just makes things way
easier so if you're a developer and need
to make sure that some services are
accessible only to your
employees or specific people but you
don't want to handle authentication that
by yourself go check it out it is pretty
cool but I mean there's something so
much stuff you had to pick ETA you've
got one say pick another one what's
another exciting 10 community side all I
was gonna do that you get that one blah
blah google.com / community is a beta
and basically it allows you to have the
communication that is editable well kind
of like basically you can send pull
requests and fix it yeah that is very
very nice very happy about that one yeah
it's gonna be great for community people
to come in and help us with our
documentation or help with tutorials and
samples I'm super excited about that
what about you oh so many I'm gonna go
with postgres nice I feel like I have to
get postcards I feel like we should give
that some love there have been so many
people who have been clamoring for
postcards for so long and I'm so happy
for it finally to be with this yes that
I am I am super super super happy about
that and for a second one second one I
like 64 core machines oh yeah give me
give me all the CPU 64 now you can
create a 64 core machines with I don't
know how many terabytes of not terabytes
of rapid like or is it terabytes nobody
is where are we we've doubled the number
of virtual CPUs you can run in an
instance from 32 to 64 and up to four
hundred and sixteen gigabytes of memory
courses so it's not terabytes yet but
you know we're now getting weird way
there yeah how about ghosts halfway
there and then you can also add eight
GPUs and you have the most powerful
machine you can you imagine thanksgiving
bother buying a machine at home like
just just use that constantly all right
so i think i think there's definitely
cool things like there's one other cool
thing i want to mention really quickly
because it came out just before next and
i think it kind of got buried a little
so there's a new issue tracker for
google cloud platform and there's one
like this is the one centralized tracker
yeah which is super cool so you can go
to issue tracker google com and you can
go there and search through it for any
public issues for basically any of our
products which is super sweet not only
Google cloud platform but actually just
google so you'll see bugs for everything
basically think that the whole point
here is not as much for you to submit
more bugs but to also track what we're
working on and what are the things we're
trying to fix
stuff like that so it's a very good
point to go and see it and also it's
just a discoverability thing right
before you kind of had to be like which
product am I looking at which bug
tracker is it working on need to go find
it now there's just one place for you to
go if you hate to submit a bug or check
on a bug this is the one place you can
do it it is definitely nice I did not
know that this existed and I used it
yesterday i was actually tracking an
issue so there you go awesome well why
don't we go have a chat with our friend
william from the home depot sounds good
let's all that I'm super excited to have
William bunnell here joining us on the
moscone floor at cloud next he is senior
director of site reliability engineering
at home depot William how you doing
today I'm doing well really excited to
be here I actually been looking forward
to talking to you guys the whole time
I've been here same same for us it's
been amazing to see home depot on the
keynote at on the floor it's been
everywhere and it's very exciting to be
able to have you to tell us a little bit
about what you're actually doing it and
home depot with a series and series and
all the cloud stuff so yeah but before
we do that you want to tell us a little
about what you do at I'm Depot what's
your role there and like what does that
involve sure so I'm responsible for the
reliability engineering strategy at the
home depot so that's kind of a broad
across the entire enterprise my specific
responsibilities in terms of teams that
I manage our e-commerce so it's a
customer facing ecommerce part of the
business and then our back-end order
management so everything we're doing
with order management we're talking you
know millions of customers per day come
to the website for processing millions
of transactions and orders on the back
end every day so I'm kind of looking at
after that every day nice so she thinks
first one is I noticed that we say home
depot and you said the home depot what
is the correct way of saying the depots
kind of low ok ok depot THD we actually
call ourselves THD like acronym and it
is like the internet guy iowa state
university and as second question is uh
what does your stack look like what are
like you said you have process a bunch
of events per day
how do you process those are you on
premise are you in the cloud well right
now we're in the middle of kind of a
hybrid we have on-premise and we have
cloud we've actually been working with
Google for about two years to move our
e-commerce platform to the Google cloud
platform so we're a little bit in a
hybrid today we actually talked about
that we had a couple a couple speaking
sessions this this this conference where
we actually talked about that
architecture so we're about 75% into the
Google cloud platform now nice i mean
we're finishing it up this year so
that's really interesting okay so but
can we get some history there like it
sounds like you were originally on pram
and then like at some point you made the
decision to shift like what happened
there why did you make that decision
sure so we had a kind of a classic
legacy ecommerce platform that we've
been running for many years and that
really got to the point where it served
us well for many years but it got to the
point where it was constraining us was
constraining us both from infrastructure
scalability standpoint very hard to kind
of scale it out plus we had a big
monolithic database that was almost
impossible to scale out at our level
scale imagine running a 5 + billion to
our website on a pretty much a single
database and of course you can scale
that up and you can do some things there
but that was constraining us but in
addition to that the velocity of our
business was constrained the throughput
of being able to deploy constant
innovation to it was constrained with
the type of platform we were on and so
we were looking for first and foremost
we were looking for building a custom
platform that would allow us to innovate
much faster we had gotten to the point
where the old platform or we could
deploy weekly that was as good as we
could do as a weekly diploma spraying it
and we want to get the point where
actually and we're doing that now we're
deploying many times a day many
different things every day nice so so
yeah you give a little bit the reasons
why you decided to move to the cloud how
did you move to the cloud so we move to
the cloud kind of chipping away one
piece at a time we actually had even
before we started working with Google we
had actually started pulling out some of
the
pieces of the e-commerce platform into a
micro services like architecture so we
might pull out something like the
product information page on the site or
could be the promotion's engine things
like that we started pulling some of
those pieces out into our on-premise
environment even before we started with
Google and then we continue with that
strategy so we say one of the first
things we launched into Google was our
store finder so that thing about store
finder is a service kind of
self-contained we can build the
development team around it they can
innovate and pushes often as they want
they don't have to go coordinate with
the team that's doing the cart in our
old platform the cart team and the store
finder team had to push their changes
together it didn't really make a whole
lot of sense but that's the way our
deployment architecture worked so
actually we we get this question kind of
all the time when people like I have
this thing and I want to move it to the
cloud how did you choose which pieces to
move when or what pot to take out was
there like a safety consideration or you
wanted to get a few feature out how did
you make those decisions yeah I mean
that's a that's kind of challenging it
really depends on I mean there's a
number of factors there one of the
things that we've been doing throughout
this migration it's taken us the last
couple years is I'm still using our on
prem ecommerce platform as the nucleus
so that's kind of the nucleus and as
we're as we're pulling pieces out we're
still kind of running things through
that kind of central hub and so that can
make calls out to services for example
that we may launch in in the Google
cloud platform so we've just been kind
of doing that piecemeal the other thing
we did was you know we did some of the
things that may be a little easier less
transactional initially like I mentioned
the store finder that's something that's
a service that doesn't have a
transactional nature it's more of a more
of a read-only type of service yeah i
think that is worth mentioning there's a
book that i've been reading about
specifically this topic like the
question you asked there's a whole book
on it yeah isn't that i'm sure there's
more than one oh yeah there's a bookcase
I think it's really good core services
book which is the o'reilly book exactly
by some newman that's exactly what i had
yes it is a very good book exactly
covering those topics so you've anyone
in the audience is curious about it I
definitely recommend it yeah and that's
actually a book and I know specifically
it was one that we had talked a lot
about internally even before we went on
this journey
there's another one also and I the name
slipping my mind but it's in a while a
book just came out recently it was
written by an SRE at uber but it's about
running microservices operating
microservices in production nice since
we're talking about books have you read
the sre book the Google I sorry book
what do you think about it yeah I most
definitely read the Google sre book
excellent book a great theme I really
like the approach where they chose real
sres within Google to actually write
chapters of their experts in that really
worked well I've read the book actually
have a been trainer signed copy of the
book which I'm very excited to be nice
that is pretty fancy so so now I'm
curious are so your director of s re at
the home depot get that right how many
PO um do you see any major differences
in terms of how you do sre THD or versus
what you've seen or at least externally
from google like has that set up for you
yep well I i'll mention it really isn't
external from google in the sense that
we've been very engaged with google's
customer reliability engineering team
we've been heavily engaged with them and
so they've helped inform us on kind of
google's way of doing sre a couple
things i would mention there is the
historical context at the home depot and
our e-commerce team is you know we kind
of historically had more of what you
might call a web engineering or web
operations team where we're kind of
managing the infrastructure where it's
more manual you know we do have some
automation in there but you know the
infrastructure itself is not is not
manual and the provisioning is much
harder so as we've evolved into the sre
model we did that at the same time as we
migrated to the Google cloud platform
and the big difference there is we're
interacting with the infrastructure
everything firewall compute storage you
name it we're interacting with it
through api's and we're provisioning
things automatically so we're no longer
logging into servers and in making
changes we're doing everything in an
automated way that's been really
important to us no longer picking up
racks of servers and this entire walls
not at all in fact that's a distant
memory for us and it hasn't it's just
something we don't even think about so
that that kinda that's a force
multiplier for us so rather than
spending those calories on that type of
work we're spending the calories on
automating our platform that is great so
you mentioned that you know sre culture
too because you were interacting with
cre could you tell us it a bit more
about your experience interacting with
them sure so so Dave renson who kind of
invented the idea of CRE created the
idea of CRE within Google and Luke stone
approached me and the probably summer
time last year with his idea and this
idea was bringing sre principles to to
customers and wondered if I'd be
interested and before they could finish
asking me the question I said yes I
would definitely be in that and you know
one of the things I think a lot about
when I'm thinking about public cloud and
I'm thinking about enterprises
considering public cloud there's a
couple big considerations for for an
enterprise one of them is course going
to be cost and so thinking about how to
how to kind of manage that properly in
the cloud is important but the second
one is reliability because if you have
an enterprise and their little nervous
back go into the cloud and they start
pushing mission critical workloads out
there and they fail regardless of
whether it's the cloud providers fault
or not they're going to potentially pull
back and so the idea of CRE is to you
know especially for very large customers
is to help them build out the practices
of reliability so that they're actually
successful when they deploy their
workloads out to the clouds not it's not
trivial so I you've been working with CR
you for quite a while I imagine is there
any any moment that you think it's like
it was fun or interesting that you could
share the weather is actually probably a
lot of a lot of moments first of all
I'll say the team AJ and Matt Brown
Adrian Hilton Luke stone Dave renson I
mean there's really crack team of I mean
this is some really talented sres I mean
one of the you know topics that we
explored even in the the happy hour with
them with bent the bends the other day
is the software engineer versus
reliability engineer how do you get the
talent into reliability engineering
teams it's clear that Google hires the
the best talent in the world into their
into their sre teams and so these guys
definitely demonstrated a very deep
understanding of how to run large-scale
production systems and so so the team
was really really really insightful they
did googly things I sorry things like
application reliability reviews and they
did deep dive actually one of the things
we talked about in the very beginning of
the conversation with with Dave and Luke
was if they were going to do this and
share fate with us and be in our black
friday war room they were they wanted us
to remediate any high risk items they
found so we agreed to that and and we
did that no actually that's it you bring
up an interesting point so I used to do
a lot of ecommerce stuff Black Friday is
a very big time for a lot of people who
do ecommerce stuff how is your black
friday ya know our block party was great
in fact Paul Gaffney RSVP of development
mentioned that in the keynote that we
actually had this last by Friday we had
half of our site in on Prem and half for
our site and Google cloud platforms a
lot of risk even there you think about
not even just in the Google cloud
platform but the interconnectivity and
so forth with our on-premise platform
and so we talked a little bit about that
in the keynote but just to cut to the
chase it was a very successful black
friday hundred percent availability
performance is rock solid and the google
cre team was right there with us they
were right there in a virtual war room
with us the whole time well
congratulations on that I know it's not
easy oh no it's not and it's getting
harder and harder I mean with the the
type of architecture the microservices
architecture and the amount of change we
have it's getting harder and harder
every year great so I curious about how
did you handle that black friday meaning
what is the what is the stack behind are
you running on compute engine what are
you doing yeah one thing I'll mention is
probably interesting and it actually
came up in my talk on Wednesday is we
didn't have to provision servers six
months in advance have only to have him
sit around for the remainder of the year
right so we actually at CRS
recommendation we actually increased our
quotas and actually bumped up our
capacity about a week before Black
Friday just in case like we lost a
region we wouldn't have any any blips
there and then that's where we got
through cyber monday we
kind of provision that back down so
right there the power of the cloud the
elasticity of the cloud right then and
there is a huge deal for us in terms of
platform was so we've been working with
Google for about two years now so some
of the choices we made were
architectural e the right choice at the
time two years ago so we're very much on
compute engine we're not running in
containers at this point but that's
mostly just because it wasn't it wasn't
mature at the time when we started doing
this managed Easton script oh yeah we're
definitely using managed instance groups
we're running out of multiple regions in
each region we have multiple zones we
actually took this opportunity we're
building our platform we actually took
the opportunity from the ground up to
build every application hot hot so
everything we have is hot hot we
actually just did a and I call it a dr
test it doesn't feel like a dr test
anymore but we just recently did a dr
test where we basically just shut all
the traffic off to the u.s. East just to
see how that would Haven I mean it was I
mean all of our workloads run hot hot so
it was a non-event for us that's that's
pretty huge for us he used the Tim hot
hot for those people who aren't familiar
what do you what do you mean by that
right so I mean active active I mean you
have an application that I mean it's in
the easiest case where you don't have a
it's not transactional that's just
deploying it to multiple in my case it's
it would be multiple data centers
multiple regions ideally in the case
where we have a transactional system you
have the data you have your back-end
data that's actually replicated across
across those regions well and you were
also talking about before like you were
hitting certain scale limits with like
your database have you actually started
moving data into Google Cloud as well
and like splitting that out or your
service yeah so every micro service if
they need a database they have a
database we generally I mean not every
not every service we have needs a
database sometimes it could be a search
platform those sorts of things but
everyone that needs a database that's a
big principle for us because in the old
world everything ran against the same
database and that created some
constraints we talked about databases
can you talk a little bit about how do
you store your data sure so an hour in
our case our primary database is
Cassandra we actually decided to kind of
self manage our own database that's
something we're actually looking at the
database platforms that are available
cloud sequel cloud datastore you
spanner spanner is actually very
exciting if you think about we're
running a I mean we're at top 10
internet retailer and you think about
our cart service and check out service
something like spanner would be very
attractive of course that's just in beta
now wasn't even it wasn't even something
we knew about other than you know the
white paper and cottage DB and so I
think we came out last week so it's
normal you having a been decorated yet
sweet Cassandra and that has been you
know Cassandra being eventually
consistent you might say hey how do you
run transactional things that in the old
world you might expect acid type of
transactions but what we found is that
the google network is so reliable and so
fast that even though cassandra is
eventually consistent it's it updates
are almost almost instantaneously so we
we see very few problems with with the
eventually consistent model there and I
know Francis is gonna ask this question
so I'm gonna jump in on that what
languages do you develop with Mac oh
sorry princess okay well thank you so
much for taking the time we actually
have a we actually have 11 of our kind
of pieces that you guys might be
interested I can tell you a little bit
about that but java's are a primary
platform okay that's primarily because
we're large enterprise and in art we at
most enterprises you would talk to like
Home Depot it's probably going to be
Java maybe you'd find net as well but
those are going to be your primary
programming languages and that was
easier for us to kind of migrated to we
are though opening up the you know the
ability for development teams to use
other development platforms that's our
primary one and you mentioned you have a
bunch of different micro services how do
you how do you communicate across them
so yep so we communicate we've actually
we communicate so internal load balancer
was not available when we decided to go
into Google and so we actually create a
mechanism and we've actually talked to
some other companies did similar sort of
things we use console for service
discovery and so we kind of built that
into our so if one service wants to call
another we go through the you know
console basically look up the service
and then and then make a direct call to
it nice and RPC wise are you using
something really like similar to grp see
the bill did you build your own thing
yeah we're just using rest restful api s
gr pc is something we're looking at
again availability of these things
you know hasn't hasn't been there yeah
it sounds also pretty new yeah yeah so
now I'm also curious we were talking
about sort of that split between going
from like monolithic on-prem and now
you're microservices how is that
impacted like your CI CD sort of your
testing infrastructure which probably
also impacts your liability except for
Cedric oh yeah I mean that's I mean it's
it's it's I mean it's like fire hose I
mean we just got just constant constant
change that's a good thing we're doing
much smaller changes when we have
problems with them we also built you
know talk about leveraging multiple
zones in multiple regions and leveraging
cloud deployment manager for doing those
deploys and being able to roll them out
and drain traffic as we need to so when
we have problems the problems are much
smaller than they were before if we're
doing a big weekly release when we had a
problem you'd feel a lot more now we're
able to do the changes you might have a
little problem so we're seeing that
teams are also this is something we're
encouraging and remember I'm the guy you
know kind of the ops guy if you will so
you know I might be the one last person
you would expect but we're encouraging
teams to spend less time not not no time
but less time on testing and performance
testing in the lower life cycle in like
a test environment just because you know
a lot of time that's just simulated
until you actually get into production
get some traffic on it get some real
customer traffic you don't really know
what you're going to get and I'm
guessing then you roll back system is
very simple and automated so like if you
put something out there maybe you put
like ten percent traffic on it see how
it does that's right yeah that's been
key to everything we're doing from the
very beginning is make sure all those
are completely automated so uh moving a
little bit away from all the tech stack
even though is super interesting you
were in the keynote tell us a little bit
about what was the message what happened
up there sure so I wasn't in the keynote
yeah I mean at the home depot depot yeah
so so Paul Gaffney spoke and one of the
things we talked about was kind of
mentioned the Black Friday that was a
big deal for us and and and for him to
talk about that as a retail you said you
were in e-commerce and how important
that is to put the trust in Google to be
able to run those kind of workload
speaks volumes and really we wanted to
kind of highlight that for for the world
and say hey this is a platform that
where we're finding highly reliable
excellent performance and
then with a CRE engagement on how to
operate these things at scale that was
kind of the message we wanted to convey
in the keynote nice and on top of that
there were also two sessions do you
remember the names so the session i did
i did with luke stone who's on the cre
team and mahesh from the network sre
team it was called 24-7 resiliency so we
kind of looked at it was Luke's I'd be
aided a great job facilitating it and in
the the idea was kind of thinking about
and actually this is actually in a
really important principle is you know
turtles all the way down you got the
network the network sre team they run
the network the cloud team doesn't
really have to know a whole lot about
what the network team is doing and
provided the network teams not causing
any issues and then the cloud the cloud
sre team is providing service to us we
don't really have to know a whole and we
don't care when you're patching load
balancers and you're patching servers
and those sorts of things we don't
really care about that we don't need to
know about that and then you come to our
lair the application we're running our
our application and RS are a team and so
it's really everybody playing their
position and doing it well excellent and
I leave us I had a micro services talk
as well yeah we had a micro services
talk on the third day Robbie odula
talked with and those names just took my
mind because it wasn't my session but we
talked about the Googlers talked about
security and load balancing and then we
reviewed kind of our micro services also
our lessons learned and I it was kind of
interesting because I think those are
the those are the sessions your
customers liked it because I could see
people like taking pictures of the
screen like the lessons learned while
taking pictures of that because that's
what that's what really resonates with
other people thinking about using google
and for all the people that were not
there we're not able to take pictures of
the screen all of those dogs were
recorded and by the time these episode
comes out there will be already online
so we'll have links to the videos on the
show notes sweet alright cool so we're
running on time just a little bit is
there anything else you want to like
highlight or plug or anything you
haven't talked about yet these things
really interesting well we talked a
little bit about that prior to this but
the question around DevOps vs s re you
know yeah what's the difference released
from my perspective and I'll true and
and and so DevOps and we actually had
you know something called DevOps within
the home depot but DevOps in most
companies I talked to seems to be much
more
see I CD build pipeline automation
related and kind of automating all those
things in the testing and deployment of
your application site reliability
engineering with the way we've
implemented it also with with our
relationship with Google's much more
around the production environment and
automating and engineering the
production environment for
high-availability performance etc so
that's that's how we've kind of
implemented it at the home depot i will
say i think you asked a question earlier
our level of i mean everybody we hire
into our team which by the way we're
hiring Home Depot's is hiring good to
know everybody we hire into our team's
going to have some kind of automation
background generally Python other other
other programming languages are fine
because we're interacting with the
Google API s but our level of software
engineering and I think comparable to
Google is probably not quite there we
want to grow it over time we think about
Google they say hey fifty percent of
their time is actually building software
we're not quite there yet but that's
something we're interested in kind of
marching toward amazing so for people
that might have companies now maybe as
big as the home depot but that are right
now on premises and they're considering
moving to the cloud what would be your
your piece of advice so I I would say
one regardless of where you host whether
it's on a cloud that you have in your
data center whether it's a google cloud
platform or a competitor you need to
build your application cloud native
right twelve factor app and all you know
all the things that kind of go into
building your application that way you
need to build it in smaller pieces so
you can do independent development and
deploy so you can get the business
velocity that would be the number one
thing but the second thing I would
mention especially when you're when
you're building applications at scale is
the operational side of it I think don't
underestimate the complexity of trying
to run all especially if you embrace a
micro services architecture don't
underestimate the complexity of running
all those pieces at four nines of
availability awesome well William thank
you so much for taking the time and
coming and hanging out here exiled next
we really appreciate you just talking to
a so it was really super fascinating my
pleasure i was really excited about
doing i appreciate you guys giving me
the opportunity thank you very much
thank you so if there's against the
william for taking the time out of his
i'm sure
or busy cloud next scheduled to talk to
us for such an interesting topic yeah
essary is one of the favorite topics
other than Cooper Nettie's maybe in the
podcast and it is always good to see how
all the people at set up google are
doing it yeah and it was also great to
hear about his experiences with cre as
well oh yeah very very cool okay so I
guess it's time to go with a question of
the week as an experiment we actually
have someone asking a question yeah we
have our friend AJ okay so let's listen
to that question yeah so cloud spanner
looks fantastic and I'm really excited
to try it out I'm wondering for a
business that's currently using
something maybe like MySQL or another
google database product when would it
make sense for them to look at switching
and why would it make sense for them to
switch so that was a great question AJ
Francis kinda you found actually a
really nice answer on Korra that we can
link to yeah we actually I searched
google what's the difference between
Google Cloud spanner and cloud sicko
yeah and i found a question on Quora
with the title what's the difference
between class fire and cloud sequel have
four children it is it is a very good
answer so we'll we'll definitely linked
to it I'm going to try to say the name
of the person that wrote the answer it's
zanko double check that seems good to me
how to check I think I jacamo if someone
knows how to pronounce I'd say that for
all with this some Slavic language if
anyone knows how to pronounce it I love
to be corrected about this genco says
the main difference is that spanner is
horizontally scalable and classical is
not what does that actually mean what it
means that clasico is vertically
scalable which means that if your server
is getting too small for you you can
make that server bigger yeah so you can
add disk you can add memory you cannot
CPUs but you cannot really add servers
yep so so once you hit that vertical
limit your kind of stuck yeah the whole
thing is that if you want more servers
you could actually do it but then you
start basically paying for the extra
cost of those sequel servers connecting
to each other and it doesn't scale
that will yeah you could do read
replicas but like you obviously like
doing right replicas yeah or we may is
yeah we replicas that doesn't work cloud
for right replicas it doesn't really
work now it's funner it allows you to do
this it basically for every note that
you add you get extra throughput so you
get extra memory extra CPUs x-ray
everything but also extra throughput
which is what you really care about
extra throughput both for reads and
writes nice so with that basically if
you have a cluster of banner nodes and
at some point you like oh we're very
close to the capacity I want to scale
this up you just add a note that's it
you don't need to do anything extra
which is really cool now you need to
take into account that yes it allows you
so spanner allows you to basically do
the same cool things that you can do a
sequel for select statement so when you
reading you can do pretty much the same
when you're writing to though the
semantics are slightly different you
cannot use sequel for now at least two
right into spanner you're going to need
to use the grp c or rest api's yeah but
these are those are like a idiomatic
api's for each language that yeah so
it's not like you're running an insert
like command rather than running inserts
yeah so basically the the thing to take
into account is that if you have
something bringing with classical and
you want to migrate spanner there's a
bit of you may need to change that a
little bit not for the rich for the
rights you may need to change it to
something to take into account now it's
also worth noting cloud spanner is going
to be a bit more expensive yes in cloud
sequel so I figure it it almost comes
down to how much data do you expect to
have or how much data do you have and
what sort of read and write throughput
do you need if maybe you have uh no
hundred thousand records or so maybe you
keep that all in cloud sequel if you
start getting into millions or billions
and you need to be able to have access
to those and interact with them in a
transactional way in a in a high read
right so the throughput way then maybe
then that's when you start looking at
something like spanner so yeah just to
give you an idea of the node / our cost
is ninety cents which is you know
nothing much but again it can go up to
like six hundred dollars something like
that I think per month so cloud tickle
you can have that
wait wait cheaper than that now the
difference is that at some point you can
make cloud sick will go faster spanner
you can always make it go faster so I'm
probably not going to move my personal
wordpress site to spanner my personal
webpage is very happily on data store
running on App Engine standard man which
means that I'm not paying for anything
there we go yep so that's very nice but
yeah if you have something way bigger
than you might press on a web page which
is basically every single project okay
you might want to use something like
this wonderful all right so now things
have calmed down a little but I think
you're jet-setting off at least in a few
weeks yeah so I'm actually staying
around San Francisco for a little bit
which you know it is not as exciting
because now we have like nice weather
hey people from New York how is it going
but afterwards my next trip is going to
be for April fifteenth and sixteenth
that will be in Gopher container in
Shanghai nice very excited about trying
to speak in Mandarin there yeah yeah
what about you so I am also staying in
San Francisco for a few weeks but then I
will be off to Vancouver are we doing a
loo made a polygon Vancouver I'll be
there presenting on gr pc and green
ladies cool now that you mentioned grp
see we should definitely talk about this
so this is coming out on 315th which is
pi plus one ooh yesterday was pi day and
we released a demo for pi babe which is
a PI API yes it's on school and it's a
grp c plus rest api with WebSockets and
all that stuff so you can basically
build visualizations on top of it if you
want to learn more about it you should
go check it out on pie delivery it's
totally a top-level domain vasilenko now
but they are piled up delivery and
you're gonna see a bunch of demos you
can like visualize pie and play pie so
you can like actually see the music but
also you're gonna see the documentation
how to use the API and all of this is
powered Google cloud platform with Club
endpoints and container engine and grill
and grp see enjoy your pc and go and you
have built it right yes oh that's why
it's go yes and that super cool actually
i was playing with that early today and
it's very very cool yeah so that that
could have been a cool thing of the week
except we forgot about it so there you
go
extra cool thing anyway but yeah cool so
yeah after I'm in Vancouver for a
polyglot meet up I'm going to be the
East Coast game developers conference
and then after that i'll PM vector that
will be from the 16th of april and the
21st respectively nice sounds lots of
fun awesome well Fran Cesc it's been a
harrowing few weeks but I'm so glad to
be back in this voiceover booth with you
thank you for taking the time once again
thank you again for taking the time and
thank you all for listening to this
episode and to every single person that
was there an ex thank you so much for
coming and saying hi absolutely and see
you all next week see y'all next week
you